The answer is going to depend on how each Z-def comparison goes. When the object
is closer than whatever is already in the Z-buffer then the cost is 3 cycles,
read the old z-def value, write the new Z-def value and then write the new
color. We call the new value coming in the source and the old value the
destination. When the object is farther away, only 1 cycle is needed. We'll
always have the cost of leaving the destination of reading the Z-Buffer depth.
When we compare the source to the destination, we get 3 cycles due to this path
of having to actually replace the old color with the new color. And the old
depth with the new depth. However, if we have the case where the source is
greater than the destination, we're done. The object's hidden, and we don't have
to do any further processing. So we only need 1 cycle. So let's look at the
answers in reverse order. Back to front order, in fact, is the worst case
possible. Since each object in turn is the closest object so far. So all values
read in the z buffer will also be written. Randomizing might help avoid worst
case behavior, but it's not the fastest way. Largest to smallest has no
predictable effect as the testing process is happening per pixel. So size
doesn't really matter. So this first answer is the correct one. Roughly sorting
and drawing objects from front to back is indeed a way in which applications
optimize GTU performance.